[Music]
the weight in between the fantastic
beast movies is far too long and we're
fresh out of time Turner's to fix that
while it still may be a few years to see
what happens in the Wizarding war we
think we've got it all figured out
so krendl rules doesn't seem to
understand the nature of things because
it is die hard Harry Potter fans know
that Dumbledore and Grindelwald have the
single greatest Wizarding duel of all
time this is the event in 1945 that
serves as the definitive ending for
Grindelwald war as cool as Dumbledore's
duel of all the more was in the order of
the Phoenix that's really not surprising
this would be Dumbledore in his prime
versus Grindelwald with the elder one we
still don't even know how Dumbledore
managed to break the blood pact or a
conqueror the unbeatable wand
Grindelwald told Voldemort that the wand
possessed the secret so maybe there's a
cheat of some kind that Dumbledore
figures out he is known for being a
tricky guy the last one hopefully the
film series dives deeper into the
possible romantic past did these two
great wizards hot as well for a duel
that's supposed to be that epic you need
a little added drama you are the only
wizard what if I told you that Snape's
tragic past as shown in Deathly Hallows
was just the tip of the iceberg during
the time period of the fantastic beasts
films Snape's mother Eileen Prince
should be at Hogwarts that is if the
film's follow all the way to the end of
the war which seems likely Grindelwald
war against both motherland wizard would
likely require muggle allies Snape's
father tobias could have been in service
to Grindelwald in exchange for the lie
that he'd become a wizard let's say he
meets Eileen Prince during the war who
also believes Grindelwald and marries
some time to come once the war is over
and it's clear to both of them that
Tobias will never be a wizard he'd
resent his magical son Severus this
abusive environment would reinforce
Snape's ideals that wizards were
superior to muggles the only real
question is Tom Hiddleston or Benedict
Cumberbatch as to buy a Snape
talk about impossible choices the entire
fantastic beasts franchise is barreling
towards the global Wizarding war that
was parallel to World War two it used to
be the defining Wizarding World conflict
before Voldemort stole grindelwald
thunder while we technically have a
Wizarding war in Deathly Hallows we
haven't seen a lot of full-scale warfare
imagine the movie 1917 or Dunkirk
but with wizards and monsters instead of
soldiers and tanks that's probably what
we have in store for us
the only thing we have to decide now is
what title they'd give to a big two-part
war epic fantastic beasts in the War of
the Wizards a Warner Bros you can get
that title if you get Eddie Redmayne to
voice our next video please don't be in
my mind The Wizarding Wars effects could
easily be felt on our favorite school
Hogwarts
since Dumbledore is obviously going to
have a bigger role moving forward
Hogwarts might be the next setting
perhaps Hogwarts is turning into a field
hospital like Downton Abbey was during
World War one Downton Abbey is a real
place right wait maybe don't answer that
seeing as Hogwarts is a magical fortress
it would make sense to use it as a
refuge can you imagine the Great Hall
used as a triage can they add in
something about how Professor McGonagall
in crimes of Grindelwald was Minerva's
mother because that cameo made every
potter head very confused not to mention
the fact that there are a few terrifying
things that we know happened at Hogwarts
during this time his name is Voldemort
said yes you might as well use it it's
going to try to kill
either way during the war Tom Riddle
started his evil bad guy career by
opening the Chamber of Secrets while we
got to see quite a few flashbacks to
this time period during the second Harry
Potter movie there are still some holes
we still don't exactly know what riddle
was trying to accomplish by using the
basilisk to attack muggle-born students
I would be able to lead another to
finish Salazar Slytherin's noble works
if Hogwarts was being used as a hospital
maybe Tom was trying to make the school
unsafe for them perhaps this was a way
of proving himself to Grindelwald
maybe he becomes one of Grendel walls
disciples in his war against the muggle
world let's be honest who doesn't want
to see Valda more it's official bad guy
origin story hopefully they do a better
job than Darth Vader's I could make bad
things happen to people who mean to me
if Tom Riddle opens the Chamber of
Secrets during the film series that
means young Hagrid gets framed for it
Hagrid becomes an expert on magical
creatures but how did he learn so much
if he did not graduate if there was a
magical creature terrorizing Hogwarts
who would Dumbledore call but his pal
knew please let us see Newt on the
basilisk that would be awesome
perhaps Newt Scamander figured out that
Hagrid was framed and took him under his
wing a young Hagrid could act as newts
new assistant throughout the series also
a war would be the perfect place for
Hagrid to score a flying motorbike maybe
he had it first before Sirius got it and
they just trade it back and forth a
motorbike timeshare oh we were all super
surprised when a human Nagini showed up
in crimes of Grindelwald but what's
coming next last we saw of her she was
at Hogwarts maybe that's where she
stayed she could have befriended a young
Tom Riddle and helped him deal with his
basilisk buddy who better to help with a
giant snake than a snake lady also this
friendship could explain why Tom decided
to go full snake face for his Volta Mort
look yeah we've been wondering about
that one for years I confess myself
disappointed man things got real when
queenie shocked us all by betraying
everyone for Grindelwald the biggest
hanging question from that film is
what's going to happen with her it
looked like she entered into a Goblet of
Fire esque deal when she crossed the
fire to Grindelwald so if she breaks it
maybe she loses her magical powers of
course this would lead to a happy ending
because she lose her painful psychic
abilities and be able to marry Jacob
she's got to have a happy ending coming
right guys right right
why do want to have a family
the one moment in crimes of Grindelwald
that made every potter head spit TIG
their soda was that infamous Creedence
scene we're all desperate to learn how
Creedence is a Dumbledore and what's
going to happen well one theory is that
he's somehow a reincarnation of Alba
says sister Ariana we know that she got
hit with a curse during the duel between
Albus Aberforth and Grindelwald that
took her life we don't know what curse
it was or why Albus was so secretive
about the moment all these years while
aside from the fact that the whole thing
is his fault
it would be kind of cool to see that
scene that was referenced in Deathly
Hallows our fourth always got the short
end of the Dumbledore stick so it would
be cool to see a younger him - if
credence aurelius accepts who he truly
is maybe he'll finally find the piece
he's been looking for you know peace and
a better haircut does this make sense
so far there's been quite a disconnect
from the newt storyline in the
Grindelwald storyline from the looks of
it
The Wizarding World is where things are
going to change we've seen new Wrangell
all sorts of beasts in the series but
what if all of those beasts end up
becoming vitally important to the war
can you imagine a scene where newt
unleashes a rumpus grap horns and none
dews and more at an army of wizards it
would be the best way to shownu for the
ultimate pokemon master that he is he
has some attachment issues come on
though to be honest what we all really
want to see new do is ride a dragon and
ride it into a world war ii battle tell
me that doesn't sound like the coolest
thing you'd ever see how could they
possibly do a battle scene better than
that
then if the Mughals saw what happened he
can always use a Thunderbird to erase
their memories again I was intending to
wait until we go to Arizona
so if Queenie and Jacob get a happy
ending how does that lead into the main
Harry Potter series well what if they
end up being Hermione Granger's maternal
grandparents this would be an incredibly
sweet way to integrate the two best
characters from the prequel series to
the main one we never learned much about
Hermione's mother so there's no reason
why she couldn't be the daughter of
Queenie and Jacob this would also
explain why Hermione was such a powerful
witch if her grandmother had suppressed
magical abilities maybe that's how she
got hers it is kind of sad that she
didn't inherit any of Jacob's awesome
baking skills say what you want about
casting magic spells but that doesn't
compare to making a good chocolate-chip
cookie that's real magic right there
some fans have been confused about how
exactly Harry Potter is so rich in the
series well if you didn't already know
his grandfather FLE Mont Potter made a
huge fortune off of his famous hair
potion and does miss daddy Potter have
his key so it would be perfect if the
series figured out how to bring fleam on
into the Wizarding war conflict a man of
his wealth would be a really great help
to the war effort and would really fill
in an important plot point also we could
see the birth of James Potter and flee
montt taking in a young serious this
could lead us right into the marauders
film series about James and his friends
that we all want
even if James is kind of a jerk
sometimes come on sniffy if Hermione and
harry's grandparents get cameos in the
series then there's definitely room for
another redheaded Weasley crimes of
Grindelwald made quite a lot of fuss
over the black family but there's
another scandal it could cover
Septimus Weasley married said Drella
black and caused quite the stir among
the black family they disapproved of
Septimus but that's hardly surprising
the black family is pretty well known
for disapproving of things that and who
wants to see their daughter marry a guy
named Septimus
thank God the Weasleys didn't name Ron
after him his life was hard enough
imagine a scene where Septimus and
Cinderella actually buy the burro to
start their family it would start us
just a little house that we all know
would become the silliest and coziest
place in the Wizarding World
you'll best hope I don't put bars on
your window Donald Weasley
the last ancestor we definitely need to
see in the series is a praxis Malfoy
Lucius Malfoy is a legendary father we
know that he participated in a
conspiracy to overthrow the minister of
magic but not much else
it wouldn't be crazy at all to see that
a praxis was part of Grindelwald army in
fact it would be a little weird if he
wasn't the Malfoy's are known for hating
muggles and other wizards more than
anything else no one asked your opinion
as far as actors go there's only one who
fits the bill as the ultimate patriarch
of the Malfoy family Charles dance who
played Tywin Lannister and Game of
Thrones can you imagine anyone else
being the father of someone as cold and
calculating as Lucius Malfoy
the fantastic beast series is going to
need to find a way to link itself to
Harry Potter and there's a great option
we know that Hagrid comes across an
amazing beast known as fluffy but it's
been a mystery as to who he got the
creature from in the books it says that
he got it from a Greek person but that
could have been a lie it would be kind
of perfect if newt was the one who gave
fluffy to Hagrid this will be the
perfect bridge to Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone Plus don't you want to
see a puppy version of fluffy a cute
three-headed little guy who just wants
to bite your head off but he doesn't
have any teeth that's a stuffed animal
that would sell better than if lured
there you have it
all of the ways that fantastic beasts
could connect to Harry Potter shout-out
to commenter Chris vakama zvika for
giving us the idea do you think that
they should follow up with a marauders
franchise let us know in the comments
and don't forget to Like and subscribe
to the things for all the best from the
Wizarding World
you